hemos visto imágenes de edificios
derrumbados por completo y ciudades
además completamente arrasadas Qué
factores han podido ser clave para estos
derrumbes tan generalizados
buenas tardes
y es el tema de la falta de normativa
actualizada o de la falta de
cumplimiento de esa normativa A falta de
bueno de hacer inspecciones in situ la
verdad es que el aspecto de los colapsos
que se observan en las estructuras
pues dejan yo creo que bastante Claro
que nos han seguido
los conceptos básicos que se han
implementado en las normas sísmicas más
modernas Osma o más recientes que hay en
los países que son adecuadamente
preparados frente a estos fenómenos
no se espera Es decir para un terremoto
de esas dimensiones aunque sea un
terremoto muy importante un edificio
proyectado según aunque sea un edificio
convencional Pero proyectado según las
normas más actuales debería sufrir daños
muy importantes incluso tener que
hacerlo Después del terremoto pero no
debería colapsar de la manera en la que
parece que lo han hecho miles edificios
en este en este sismo y que necesitaría
un edificio moderno para no colapsar
ante este tipo de sismos porque vemos
por ejemplo el caso de Chile un lugar de
constante sismos en los que no se
registra normalmente tal destrucción
Bueno hoy en día Existen dos estrategias
para proyectar estructuras frente a
terremotos la primera consiste en lo que
podríamos considerar las
la estrategia convencional las
estructuras convencionales y la segunda
son las estructuras avanzadas que
incorporan sistemas innovativos que se
han venido desarrollando en los últimos
años no las estructuras convencionales
se proyectan para que puedan deformarse
lateralmente puedan sufrir daños pero
sin colapsar Para ello se eligen unas
determinadas zonas de la estructura que
suelen ser los arranques de los Pilares
y los extremos de las vigas para que
solamente esas zonas plastifiquen quiere
decir que allí los elementos
estructurales experimenten deformaciones
plásticas Y de esa manera disipen
energía pero sin que comprometan lo que
es la estabilidad de todo el edificio y
después estarían las estructuras
avanzadas de las hay en sí de las hay en
Estados Unidos aquí en Japón sobre todo
en este último país que Son estructuras
que incorporan dispositivos especiales
una de las soluciones son los llamados
disipadores de energía que son Pues algo
parecido a los amortiguadores que tienen
los vehículos por ejemplo y que son
elementos que protegen la estructura
frente a daños y después un terremoto de
esas características por la estructura
que da prácticamente Sin daños y lo
único que hay que hacer es en todo caso
sustituir estos disipadores
usted claramente no está ya ni en
Turquía ni en Siria pero cree que los de
edificios que hayan quedado en pie a la
vista de las imágenes podrán ser
habitables de nuevo o un terremoto de
tal magnitud deja roturas irreparables
en edificios no preparados para ello
bueno habría que hacer una inspección
caso por caso para poder tomar una
decisión y una determinación sobre eso
pero
me Temo que muchos de ellos
efectivamente
[Música]
no es más remedio que demolerlos
solamente
el hecho de que tuviesen por ejemplo
desplazamientos horizontales permanentes
pues superiores del orden de lo que es
el 0,5% de la altura de las plantas y es
un edificio que económicamente no se
puede recuperar y que demolerlo con lo
cual efectivamente muchos de ellos
seguramente
su fin es su destino va a ser ese además
tenga en cuenta que el tema de los de
las réplicas es terrible es decir la
réplicas actúan sobre estructuras que se
han yarañadas con lo cual pueden ser
bueno pues la puntilla que acabe que
acabe provocando el colapso de la
estructura